you're watching a Valley's most accurate
forecast on 8 news now and before we get
to our local weather take a look at the
rain and tornadoes oh my God hammering
the south at least two deaths have been
reported in Louisiana you can see from
the damaged trees power lines down major
damage to homes and then farther north
it is blizzards in Colorado and Nebraska
over 10 000 flight delays and
cancellations we'll show you where that
storm is in just a minute but as we
continue to monitor the storms that have
been pummeling your family and friends
take a look we are doing great here this
is a camera on top of the Bank of
America at Rainbow in the 95. the flag
moving around a little bit we've got
North winds but a generally Blue Sky
let's take a look at the temperatures in
your neighborhoods we know 49 is the
official number out at Reed
International but what's happening where
you are well we do have readings in the
mid 40s Summerlin 45 warm spot that's
going to be the Air Force Base at 15
again breezes to 10 15 even 20 miles an
hour time and take a look at Kyle Kenny
just barely at the freezing Mark we have
seen temperatures in the teens during
the overnight hours and speaking of that
let's go to Nevada and Beyond some snow
flurries for parts of Lincoln County
southwest Utah although all the weather
watches and warnings and how much
further to the north and to the east
over the Huffman property at 44 45 for
Kingman 48 in Laughlin we made it to 51
yesterday that's exactly where we think
we're going to end up today I mean we're
at 49 right now so we could end up
busting that to maybe 52 but there's a
normal high for this time here at 56.
low this morning around the freezing
Mark the normal low for this time of
year would be 39 and take a look the sun
getting up at 6 43 going to bed just
before 4 30. okay let's check in with
those three p's when we have lows that
are going to be around the freezing Mark
you want to protect your pets your pipes
and your plants if you don't think the
little kitties or dogs can handle the
outdoors just bring them in if you think
your pipes might freeze wrap them up or
just let them drip for a little bit if
you have plants that you think can
survive you want to cover them up with
cloth some people add a couple of more
peas you want to protect people if you
want to check in on your family or
friends or whatever and also check in on
the pool make sure that doesn't freeze
so there's the storm system we got rid
of it is causing the snow to the north
and tornado watches continuing across
the Deep South Ted florinda will have
the latest on that for you later on this
afternoon here's your eight day accurate
forecast maybe 52 under the sunshine
tomorrow another round of clouds Will
Roll in but overnight lows below the
freezing Mark daytime highs may be in
the upper 40s and we hope the Jewish
committee celebrate the beginning of
Hanukkah at sundown on Sunday Christian
all right Nate thank you for that we'll